こんにちは和美社長ですすいません
何度こういう動画を出したらいいのかと
思う
今回が一番思っています僕が誰より一番を
持っていると思うんですけども a
今回は
結構
命に関わりそうなヤバさでたぶんこのよう
には進めない状態です
今まで何台を出してきましたよきた時は
ナイフラインがないとか輸注バーの仕事を
してるからソネットがないと本当に生活
できない両方正しい次いではないんです
今回も釣りじゃないです今こう元気に
ペラペラしゃべってますけどもただいま
静岡市静岡県静岡市の気温33度です
危ない姫像に危ないんですよそしてそれが
このいいとどう関係があるのかやれはじめ
お前の家は3億円の後てだそんな外が担保
暑かろうといえてキンキンに冷えてアゾ
ラグジュアリーな生活をしているであろう
と思うじゃないですか
エアコンないんですよ
ん
喋ってるだけで汗かく浮世絵ちょうどいい
ますね元気そうにしゃべってますけども
結構ギリギリちょっとフラフラするんじゃ
ないと苦しさで動画を撮らせていただいて
おりますだいぶ日が落ちてきてようやく
ギリギリ動画とるなぐらいの感じな手間
とらせていただいてるんですけども
あぶないいっすよ暑すぎて皆さんあの熱中
症本当に気を付けて下さい金な場所によっ
ては2ほんでももう40度超えている場所
があるとか酒造がもう許ずーっと30度
越えですよで僕あの部活で
バスケットボールバスケやってたんです
けども熱中症ってもちろん外はないんです
けども橘内かなり危ないんですよバステト
か筆内の熱中症って実はめちゃくちゃ多く
ていろんなようになると思いますけども風
がないちょっとだと風が吹いてたりしてる
んでまぁ干潟とかして影にいれば結構いい
感じで涼しく言ってるんですけど質だ言っ
て風がないか空気がこもっに苦しさせこの
3件のうち外壁見たらわかると思うんです
けどコンクリートでできてるんですよ
だいぶマシにはなったんですけどもう家の
造り見たらわかると思うんですけどこれは
もう
コンクリートなんですよあらゆる壁がここ
度も全部コンプリート zepp
コンクリートなんですよこの家ですよね僕
もそんな中を打ち詳しいわけではないん
ですけども多分なんですけども他のお家
より絶対に熱がこもりやすい全部昆布いう
ダンスうちいや今本当に外に行ったほうが
涼しい風丸4
ちょっとねぇ
夏舐めてたねこんなにゃっつ員だ道ぐらい
も苦しくて
どーっとせてももう汗帰ってくるんですよ
まず峰気をつけてね俺だけじゃない気休め
は今だけ苦しんだけど家買ったのが確か
去年の夏の終わりだったから夏本番はまだ
この家で過ごすことはなくてちょっと
初めての夏の3県のおうち
かなります危険を感じております
[音楽]
ん
3億円で買ったか思えないぐらいもあれ
一発ですねなんかっす
びっくりですよモーゼ嬉しいですね
[音楽]
普通には不向きです
南海という3億円の家なんですけど
本当に熱くて
特にものと1階2階
7月かなりあの撮影であったりとかで
あの一緒に過ごすことが多いんですけど
とにかく1階2階だちょっと熱すぎて
ほんと一さんが撮影しているときは僕基本
はの四回に2死変に逃げています
はいそのぐらいちょっと暑いです本当に
なんとかしていただきたい初めてお願いし
ますというわけでどうしてこうなって
しまったのかちょっと髪の方に選んで弾い
ていきたいと思います宜しくおねマス
ありますします彼にですよろしくお願いし
ます
年間配
おうちが熱いですねうーんまさにそうです
よね嫌がっ
麺がネタだと思われてますけど本当お仕事
ね他のスタッフさんとか事務所の一曲です
けど
みんな全部合わせなってて仕事ができない
だけであって3回と4回いっただーで34
回だね編集部屋と寝室寝る場所だけは空調
が効いててそこでは一応寝たりは出来るん
です詐欺もどきですけどこういう撮影する
部屋とかあと2回の音天てればスネア外川
も抹茶くくぅ直聞かずコンクリートで活動
とにも悪く
とんでもないん状況が出るという承知で
ございます皆様でございますからねこれは
ですねあの現状をお伝えするとお願いし
ます今もう
工事お願いしますっていうのをもう発注
済みですって問題はやっぱりコロナ
やっぱりまだ流行ってますので半導体で
ものが入ってこないらしいんですよ空調
機器自体なるほどそれでちょっと遅れて
いる反動台作ります今日てぞぬ道なものは
お願いして業者の方もだいたい何時から
何時までに終わるでしょうみたいで
スケジュールは組みもらってるんですなぁ
ドナルド僕が聞いてるあの工事完了の端
筆記道っていうかだいたい夏のおりてぃ
ます夏の割れなぜ
[音楽]
竜踊切られ的ないっていうやばいねーまだ
夏の本番こんなことになるんだって思って
なかったのもあるし
その最近のこの日本の気温がいいぞって
いうのも
ちょっと通っと苦しい苦しいです
ついに影響がねちょっと出ちゃうんですよ
ねだがコンクリートは熱を吸収するらしい
ですはい外からつい日差しが着るとその
コンクリートが月を底に蓄積してそれを
部屋の中でかーっっ恐ろしくてそれが
なかなか下がらないらしいんですよ猫まあ
そうちゃってるからね持って下がらない
状態がずっと続いてるんで余計外ああっ
そこらへんのさあエアコンない eu が
熱いを得ずあついあついあつい絶対
ツイート酢ガラスばりの場所も多いんで
次回行ってみましょうか魔女だねああああ
相当そうそうこういう場所だねうん
カサドールからねってかさをとの関係上
さあば密室じゃないと取れないじゃん効果
そう
ですか入りましょうん
女性は体育お願いしますします
春入った瞬間もはちょっとねやっぱ風が
ないのがね良くないな
いやーこのヘイトが熱いですね
まさにそれ
[音楽]
そうねここで結構太陽光が入ってきたりと
か本当にっていうのはかっこいいんだけど
そういうとこなんだよなぁ架空ちょっと
いうのは声がなるってことをこれがバック
長官のナナバールで壊れて使えますはい
はい分かったこれ危険ずは聞け
東京のうち避難しますはぁそれが一番賢い
んですか
[笑い]
ブービー以下
[音楽]
あんにょん溝とで見た目とかもそうです
けど空調とか便器からもどんどん進化して
いったりとかちょっとも自制的にマジで半
導体とかそのものが入んなくて普通に拾っ
て悪いけど引き続き会社がよろしくお願い
たいと話しましたうんちく実行オプション
世界でした
プール行きたいです
あっ
[音楽]
は blr